matt tu as beaucoup changé de look on a
fait une frise de thé vous a toujours
été beau gosse toi moi tu as une chance
tu vois c'est si c'est vrai alors on va
commencer avec toi tout jeune tu étais
déjà habitué à être incognito face aux
paparazzi regarde jamais reçue petit
palmier la voix c'est ouais mais lui
c'est un gars ensemble une punition ça
quand même noguero toi tu as toujours
été frais en fait j'avais connu le bail
de tu te dis je sors qu'ils chuchotent
je devais avoir des dossiers quittera
non bâti on dirait l'autre
elle est magnifique il est banni non
mais sans rival effrayant on dirait la
normalement c'est les gars vous savez
ricky ou la belle vie deux heures les
frères in a lui déjà cet âge là tu dois
voir la colère je crois que j'étais en
sixième
ah ouais il contrôle le clip d'elle me
contrer grazia mérite ne met pas non sa
famille ont arrêté sa part la meilleure
alors là tu as fait la barre ce qu'on
appelle à la schola laspalès faire ce
qu'on appelait dans lunel à robert hue
la robert hue à damas des relégables
avec lui et on dirait un vrai joueur
s'est laissé pousser pour robin des bois
les cheveux mais c'est bien des
vestiaires le problème avec matt pokora
j'vous jure t revo pigments garni c'est
qu'à un moment on essaie de trouver des
salles photo on n'a pas trouvé
je trouverais moi je tends vers un ta
prochaine fois tu m'as mercredi regardez
regardez après il ya d'autres détenus
regardez ouais c'est pas mal c'est pas
mal aussi
julie raynaud qu'est ce qui vous le dis
si vous nous rejoignez julie raynaud m'a
envoyé un sms à leur triomphe tuset
bâfrer chaussures matt pokora
elle m'a dit elle m'a dit voilà moi je
qu'est ce qu'elles lui feraient bien
décoller sa fusée à matt pokora qui je
ne sais pas quelle je sais pas ce qui se
confondent lg je croise un autre
pourquoi
merci et je vous dis je vais revenir
plus souvent et je vous dis assez
motivant ça s'est posé sur la lune mater
mon style non match je sais que vous
êtes parti oui mais voilà et c'est quand
même une très belle fille c'est une
belle femme oui quand même
vous êtes magnifique alors il ya un bon
soir comment allez-vous ça va vous aviez
bien vu on sait on s'est déjà vu
d'ailleurs vous êtes voyons oui ces
voyants astrologues c'est quoi alors
voyons un astrologue d'accord très bien
alors matt ton petit rappel les planètes
est ce que tu crois en l'astrologie ou
pas du oui ouais ouais un peu ta dire
consulter une voyante
non parce que j'ai peur de savoir l'as
vence a peur de sabre à la main alors
maths alors donc voilà j'ai l'impression
que je fais si tu vivras votre hôtel
juste avant de venir donc voir si vous
voulez bien alors vous allez il va des
banques vous avez déjà fait un truc avec
des cartes exactement ce qu'il va faire
il doit choisir une carte alors de
scanners pour voir un peu justement
match
si vous permettez nous donc encore à
bonjour bonjour
donc je vous montrais ce jeu de cartes
et bien c'est très sympa que julie
raynaud sur cette séquence avec votre
main vous allez juste coupé le jeu est
juste juste avant alors est-ce que vous
ce que nous on est quelqu'un qui lisait
dans la choucroute parents vous vous
lisez dans quoi alors écoutez j'ai
d'autres supports effectivement comme le
chocolat
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]